Perú ese país que parece cambiar de
gobierno casi tanto como de estaciones
nos ha dado los últimos cinco años todo
un espectáculo de inestabilidad política
seis presidentes decenas decenas y
decenas de ministros y un congreso
totalmente paralizado desde el cese
forzado del presidente Pedro Pablo
kuczynski en marzo del 2018 las
instituciones peruanas parecen haber
entrado en algo así como una Tormenta
perfecta una tormenta donde cualquiera
que se arriesga a pescar en río revuelto
puede sacar algún botín Aunque eso sí
seguramente luego Terminé con el rosario
de la Aurora esto es con un enorme caos
Si no recordemos al malogrado presidente
Pedro Castillo llegó la presidencia con
apenas una base del
18,92% de los votos en primera vuelta
prometió un gran cambio protagonizó una
guerra campal contra el congreso y ahora
su gobierno es de historia y él está en
la cárcel ahora bien toda esta sucesión
de idas y vueltas caos líos
inestabilidad y parálisis política es
cosa solo de los políticos peruanos o
alguien más está sacando Pro vecho de
ello pues prestas mucha pero que
muchísima atención
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el día 7 de diciembre del 2022 Dina
boluarte asumió la presidencia del Perú
después de que el anterior presidente
Pedro Castillo intentará llevar a cabo
un absurdo improvisado y mal gestionado
golpe de estado que terminó expulsándolo
del Poder y a pesar de que boluarte
procede del núcleo de poder del gobierno
de Castillo digamos que supo pasar
página y romper lazos para hacerse con
la presidencia Claro que entonces
numerosos focos de protestas estallaron
a lo largo y ancho de todo el país
especialmente las localidades andinas
por momentos estas protestas incendiaron
El Perú y para que os hagáis una idea en
el momento de preparar Este vídeo se
contabilizan 66 fallecidos y un montón
de problemas económicos en un primer
momento las manifestaciones tenían como
objetivo pedir la renuncia de boluarte
Sin embargo poco a poco en el sur del
país las protestas tomaron otro tinte
muy diferente de repente es objetivo
empezó a hacer algo mucho pero que mucho
más disruptivo cuyas implicaciones
pueden no solo extenderse en el tiempo
sino incluso amenazar la propia
integridad del Perú queridos amigos
amigas cada vez son más los grupos que
apuestan por impulsar un movimiento
secesionista a favor de la independencia
del Gran Sur del país ahora bien Hasta
qué punto Hablamos de una amenaza real
qué intereses están detrás de toda esta
historia se puede realmente romper el
Perú Pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
una historia llena de roces
Ya sabéis que en visualpolitik muchas
veces nos gusta recurrir la historia
para construir un contexto sobre la
actualidad sin embargo en este caso
podéis creerme si os digo que la
historia se parece Más al presente de lo
que nos podamos imaginar Así que para
entender dónde nacen las
reivindicaciones independentistas del
Sur del Perú tenemos que entender
primero Cómo se compusieron sus
fronteras y es que fijaos cuando esta
nación se independizó en el año 1821 se
creó el conocido como protectorado de
San Martín en el Perú Un gobierno
provisional que tuvo al frente al
libertador argentino José Francisco de
San Martín Claro que al poco tiempo
renunció y le cedió el testigo a la
suprema junta gubernativa del Perú una
especie de gobierno designado por el
primer Congreso Constituyente de este
país Claro que en ese momento la guerra
contra la corona española todavía
continuaba no solo en el Perú sino
también en la mayor parte de la región
de esta forma en agosto del año 1825 se
proclamó la Independencia de la
República de Bolívar la cual
Posteriormente se renombró como Bolivia
y aquí lo más importante para muchos
esta nueva nación representaba por sus
lazos sociales culturales económicos y
hasta territoriales un claro
expansionismo del bolivarianismo en la
zona de influencia de Lima Así que el
choque entre las distintas facciones
estaba servido
en 1828 aún con el conflicto con España
vivo en ciertas zonas los peruanos
organizaron para lanzar una invasión
militar sobre Bolivia con el fin de
forzar La retirada de la zona de Antonio
José de sucre que era aleala Bolívar
digamos que los peruanos no se fiaban
del libertador venezolano y bueno al fin
y al cabo su gran héroe de la
independencia había sido San Martín pero
ojo porque esto fue tan solo el comienzo
entre los años 1834 y 1835 estallaron
varios conflictos en el Perú en el
último de ellos Los Rebeldes al entonces
gobierno de Felipe salaverry buscaron
ayuda en el gobierno boliviano quien
aceptó intervenir en el conflicto los
bolivianos lanzaron una excursión
militar conocida como la guerra de
pacificación del Perú de esta forma Los
rebeldes apoyados por Bolivia se
hicieron con el poder en Lima y
redoblaron la apuesta creando en 1836 la
confederación Perú boliviana ante esta
situación los peruanos que resistieron
buscaron la ayuda de chile y quien
aceptó contribuir a la creación de un
ejército Unido restaurador el cual logró
revertir la situación en el año 1839
cuando se dio por disuelta esta
confederación
El peor de los miedos para buena parte
de la élite peruana se había hecho
realidad Bolivia era un actor peligroso
y una auténtica amenaza para su
soberanía Así que a pesar de haber
acordado una tregua tras la disolución
de la confederación Perú boliviana los
peruanos invadieron nuevamente Bolivia
en 1841 claro que esta vez no tuvieron
mucho éxito y al final el tratado de
puno del 42 generó una paz algo más
duradera una paz que incluso generó
algún que otro vínculo amistoso entre
ambos países por ejemplo en 1879 Bolivia
se vio envuelta en otro conflicto
militar en este caso con chile fue la
denominada guerra del Pacífico donde
Perú acudió en auxilio del ejército
boliviano por un tratado de Alianza
defensiva que se había llegado a firmar
en secreto en 1873 menudo jaleo
este periodo además es clave porque en
1880 4 años antes de que se alcanzara la
paz ambos países habían llegado a
consensuar un plan legislativo conjunto
para crear los Estados Unidos Perú
bolivianos Aunque al final de este
proyecto no cuajó
[Música]
ya lo veis todo una historia de amor y
odio de convivir juntos en una
confederación a invadirse constantemente
entre sí para luego apoyarse en una
guerra como un contra chile El caso es
que la idea de volver a vivir en un
mismo país quedó completamente
desplazada en el siglo XX Claro que
tarde o temprano Alguien podría volver a
tomar esa bandera y sabéis que eso es
exactamente lo que pasó
[Música]
el revisionismo bolivariano
amigos amigas a estas alturas creo que
todos sabemos que si los movimientos
populistas tienen alguna adicción Esa no
es otra que reescribir los libros de
historia por supuesto para formar un
relato a su favor Esto es algo que
durante la construcción del llamado
socialismo del siglo XXI sucedió en
múltiples sentidos queréis una prueba
pues fijaos Simón Bolívar previó el
socialismo pues como también previó el
imperialismo norteamericano y así lo
dijo los Estados Unidos de Norteamérica
parecen destinados para plagar la
América de miserias a nombre de la
libertad eso lo dijo Bolívar la
revolución bolivariana llegó a convertir
en una especie de líder socialista Simón
Bolívar un miembro de la oligarquía de
la época del que karl Marx decía
lindezas como estas Bolívar es el
canalla más cobarde brutal y miserable
karl Marx en una carta friedrich engels
en 1858 Pues bien El caso es que esto no
fue un bíceps exclusivo de la Revolución
bolivariana cuando Evo Morales llegó al
poder en Bolivia en 2006 también empezó
a jugar con la historia en este caso el
relanzamiento de la confederación
peruana tomó cada vez más y más peso
Claro que no sólo fue cosa de Evo
eventualmente el presidente peruano
ollanta humala quien gobernó el país
entre 2011 y 2016 también empezó a
compartir el sueño de Morales fijaos yo
sueño con la reunificación del Perú y
Bolivia sueño que en algún momento esa
línea fronteriza desaparezca y volvamos
a hacer una misma nación un solo país y
por supuesto Evo Morales pues no dejó de
insistir con este tema 2 de noviembre de
2015 Evo Morales chile Busca intimidar a
Bolivia y Perú con ejercicio militar
Nosotros también podríamos decir que hay
que reconstruir la confederación Perú
boliviana pero no se trata de eso lo que
se trata es de entender que no estamos
en tiempos de Invasión son tiempos de
integración oligarquía de chile y
derecha boliviana tutelada por Estados
Unidos conspiran contra el país estaba
repasando los datos históricos y un día
como hoy 1836 El Congreso de chile
aprueba una declaración de guerra a la
confederación peruano boliviana por
entonces Bolivia era el país más
próspero de la región la oligarquía
chilena empieza a conspirar a esta gran
unidad entre Perú y Bolivia de hecho
cada dos por tres metía mensajes en sus
redes sociales sobre esta antigua
confederación su empeño en reflotar y
liderar esta bandera parece bastante
pero que bastante claro
y luego para colmo llegó Pedro Castillo
a la presidencia del Perú 30 de octubre
de 2021 es un momento de reafirmar la
identidad porque nos alberga el mismo
suelo la misma historia sueño y
esperanza no miramos límites entre Perú
y Bolivia estar en la paz estar en
Bolivia es igual que estar en la
cuna que me vio nacer la tierra De donde
vengo Pedro Castillo ex presidente del
Perú ya lo veis poco a poco la idea de
recrear una nueva nación conjunta fue
cogiendo más y más fuerza Claro que en
2019 su principal impulsor Evo Morales
perdió el poder lo que queridos amigos
amigas no hizo que sus esfuerzos se
disiparan sino todo lo contrario
[Música]
runasur el punto de inflexión
en diciembre de 2020 Evo Morales dio a
conocer la creación de runa sur Una
entidad cuyo nombre surge de la Unión de
las palabras runa que significa persona
en quechua y unasur la unión de Naciones
suramericanas supuestamente esta
organización tenía como objetivo servir
como mecanismo de integración
plurinacional entre los pueblos
indígenas los afrodescendientes las
organizaciones sindicales las
territoriales y los movimientos sociales
de la región todo junto Pues bien en
esta entidad se aglomeran hoy en día los
principales movimientos indigenistas de
la izquierda en Latinoamérica algunos de
ellos incluso con un enorme poder de
movilización como es el caso por ejemplo
de la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas de Ecuador quien por ejemplo
en junio del 2022 puso en jaque las
políticas económicas de Guillermo lasso
de la resistencia a la toma del Poder y
en Bolivia Hemos cumplido hermanas y
hermanos
el bonito indígena queridos amigos una
sola ha supuesto un auténtico punto de
inflexión a los antecedentes históricos
a las múltiples llamadas de Evo a la
reunificación boliviana peruana ahora se
sube una plataforma con poder de
movilización y organización y ahora la
crisis política en Perú puede haber
encendido la Mecha pero ahora bien en
qué piensa exactamente Evo Morales
cuando habla de reunificación que tiene
en mente Pues bien veámoslo
agitando el avispero
con todo lo que Evo Morales parece haber
soñado con la reunificación de la
confederación Perú boliviana Es evidente
que la llegada de Pedro Castillo era
todo una oportunidad una oportunidad
única para avanzar hacia esa dirección
26 de julio de 2021 Evo Morales llegó a
Perú para asistir a la Asunción de
Castillo el exmandatario boliviano
2006-2019 llamó a los gobiernos de ambos
países a diseñar una agenda binacional y
agregó sería el mejor homenaje a
nuestros próceres que intentaron la
unidad en la confederación peruano
boliviana sin embargo la caída de
castillo y el cambio de gobierno supuso
que nuevamente ese proyecto esa nueva
bandera de Evo Morales quedaba en saco
roto Excepto si la ingobernabilidad el
caos y las protestas fueran capaces de
alimentar que una mayoría social
comprase de una vez por todas ese
discurso y tal y como decíamos por aquí
dicho y hecho fijaos el fantasma de una
secesión aparece en medio de la crisis
política peruana los limeños nos quitan
el derecho a consulta popular a nuestro
presidente y hemos elegido
mayoritariamente Pedro Castillo lo
tienen secuestrado están asesinando y
los muertos son del sur no del centro ni
del Felipe Domínguez líder del frente de
defensa del cono norte de Arequipa Perú
prohíbe el ingreso de Evo Morales por
afectar la seguridad nacional en los
últimos meses se ha identificado a
ciudadanos extranjeros de nacionalidad
boliviana que ingresaron al país para
efectuar actividades de índole política
remarcó el Ministerio de interior en un
comunicado 26 de enero de 2023
declaramos persona no grata al Señor Evo
Morales ahuma en el territorio nacional
por sus constantes incitaciones en la
política nacional las mismas que buscan
desequilibrar el orden interno del país
en especial la zona del Sur del Perú
moción presentada por la congresista
María del Carmen Alba y aprobada con 74
votos a favor ahora bien en qué está
pensando exactamente Evo Morales cuando
habla de la reunificación
[Música]
pues veréis estrictamente no habla de la
Unión de los dos países sino de la
secesión de una parte del Perú para
constituir una república que luego
podría formar una especie de
confederación con Bolivia en concreto el
proyecto pasaría por la creación de una
República independiente donde tomen
parte de los departamentos de Arequipa
ayacucho Apurímac cusco madre de Dios
moquegua puno y tacna estas zonas son
muy ricas en recursos minerales y
abarcan a seis de los 33 millones de
habitantes que tiene el Perú
[Música]
en este escenario la localidad más
apegada a la idea de la independencia
sería puno no tanto por la crisis
política como sobre todo por los
aspectos económicos y culturales el sur
de puno es culturalmente muy similar al
altiplano boliviano hay una cercanía muy
grande que se nota en las costumbres y
en Cómo se viste la gente y también en
episodios históricos como el intento de
establecer una confederación peruana
boliviana en 1836 Ramiro Escobar experto
en relaciones internacionales de la
pontificia Universidad Católica del Perú
por eso puno ha sido precisamente uno de
los epicentros de las principales
protestas de los paros y de los bloqueos
en vías en contra de Dilma boluarte en
la zona operan lo que la propia
presidenta describió como los ponchos
rojos una agrupación de manifestantes
bolivianos que presuntamente estarían
Traficando armas para promover una
escalada de violencia en la zona y ojo
Porque estos movimientos van mucho más
allá de las protestas que se produjeron
tras la caída de Castillo digamos que
tienen un proyecto de mucho más largo
plazo y no no hablamos de la vía Armada
todo apunta a que la idea sería Buscar
un camino constitucional que facilitará
el proyecto del ex presidente boliviano
en un futuro no muy lejano y sabéis que
por ahí van los tiros atentos
[Música]
una nueva constitución a la vuelta de la
esquina
desde que dio comienzo el 2023
diferentes encuestas han mostrado un
alto nivel de apoyo Popular a la idea de
reformar o incluso generar una nueva
constitución en el Perú y claro aprobar
una nueva constitución con tanta
convulsión social puede determinar
abriendo las puertas para que se apruebe
de todo y sabéis que Evo Morales parece
tenerlo muy pero que muy claro fijaos
algunos pequeños grupos aprovechando la
prensa me van declarando persona no
grata dicen que Evo no debe entrar a
Perú pero el verdadero pueblo pueblo
cómo sería si entrara Perú te imaginas
en este momento sería una aclamación
como una proclamación Evo Morales 29 de
enero de 2023 queridos amigos amigas
últimamente El Perú no va por buen
camino os hemos hablado de ello tanto
aquí en visualpolitik como en nuestro
canal hermano visual economic Y la
verdad es que si algo está claro es que
entre unas cosas y otras la clase
política peruana está consiguiendo echar
por tierra a la que era una de las
economías más prometedoras de toda
América Latina los movimientos
independentistas ahora pueden terminar
convirtiéndose en el último Jaque al
Estado peruano pero o sea como se ha
llegado hasta aquí turno para ti sabías
Perú y Bolivia han tenido un pasado con
tantos amores y odios crees que Evo
Morales se saldrá con la suya y logrará
alimentar un amplio movimiento
independentista en el Perú y quizás la
pregunta más importante de todas
conseguirás romper el Perú dejadnos por
aquí abajo todos vuestros comentarios y
hablamos debate Y por supuesto si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like y
suscribiros al politik si es que aún no
lo habéis hecho una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]